the prayers of skiers and snowboarders
being answered thanks to the wet weather
we are seeing and despite early warnings
potentially hundreds more will be
sharing the slopes this weekend Matthew
shows us the event lineup what it could
mean for the Lee Canyon Ski Resort's
bottom line
[Music]
more snow more demand here on Mount
Charleston and it's expected to get even
busier than this it's with an
event-filled weekend and with those
bigger crowds bigger revenue from those
bracing the cold
and up to two feet of new snow could
Land by the weekend perfectly packed
they groom it really well afterwards so
it's much easier to Glide and get
through the trees but Kennedy Williams
won't be alone when she returns this
weekend
at the Lee Canyon Ski Resort higher than
average visitors are expected starting
Friday a trio of good snow a holiday
weekend and a popular tournament the 8th
Annual Chris Ruby cup benefiting the
Nevada donor Network and a three-day
weekend with the Martin Luther King Jr
holiday this Monday as holiday weekends
are always jamming it comes after a peak
visitation weekend that periodically
shut down parking representing hundreds
of customers and wallets if they're
anything like Aaron chernoff they're
spending a hundred dollars at least each
yeah get food take breaks the lift pass
of course it's gone up about ten dollars
for locals in the last year that's the
chair of the Reynolds and if they're
like Dan Larson it's nearly two hundred
dollars each because I love to ski and I
only have a couple more years with these
knees and so I'm a
do it while I can despite the early
warnings gear saved they'll be back but
brace for traffic as families look to go
sledding and play in the snow it's worth
you know the traffic and the weight and
all of the crowds the fresh powder is
it's worth it